hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
imagine being able to play any game at
full speed and resolution with nothing
else but a screen and internet
connection and a controller no
PlayStation no Xbox not any kind of
hardware that you have to buy it to make
your game run what if your game ran on a
server on the other side of the world
and simply fed you the output on your
screen
welcome to Google's newest product and
their future vision to revolutionize
gaming
it's called stadia and it's a big move
[Music]
recently on the 19th of March 2019
Google announced stadia at the Game
Developers Conference in San Diego the
idea is simple but revolutionary
to understand why we need to first
understand the current problems with
gaming up until now gamers had to invest
in hardware in order to play this may be
in the form of Sony's PlayStation
Microsoft's Xbox or a laptop or PC with
the right amount of RAM strong graphics
hardware etc then users had to buy a
game disk or download the game onto
their device which was limited to the
type of console this means that you
can't bury a friend's xbox version of a
game to play on your PlayStation online
gaming is also mostly limited to your
console meaning their Xbox and
PlayStation gamers rarely play each
other in Google's stadia a user can play
a cross platform without the need for
hardware apart from a controller the
screen can be your phone laptop or even
your TV google has released a special
controller but have said that you can
use any controller keyboard or mouse the
demonstration that GDC shows just how
easy it all is imagine you are watching
games on YouTube and you discover the
latest Assassin's Creed Odyssey trailer
on Ubisoft's official channels on
youtubers you will notice the Play Now
button by simply clicking on that button
the player is brought directly into the
game in a browser in as quick as 5
seconds with stadia this waiting game
will be a thing of the past and just
like that you can go from watching a
youtube video about a game to actually
play in the full high-resolution game on
that same device with no hardware
acceleration there is basically no
hardware acceleration on that laptop
whatsoever and the game is running
directly from our data center it's then
easy and instantaneous to move that same
game experience from exactly that moment
on to the phone here on a pixel 3xl this
is great innovation and actually a smart
move for Google they already own YouTube
or about 15% of all videos relate to
gaming in addition 64% of the US
population above 13 years old play video
games which is an ever-rising
year-on-year number
stadia is the plural of Stadium the idea
is that stadiums are places where you
can either play or watch games which is
Google's vision for the final product so
this is clearly a revolutionary idea but
will it live up to the hype since
nothing is downloaded to your device
this means that the whole game is
processed on Google's servers and that
in turn means that you need fast
internet to stream 1080p at 60 frames
per second requires a 25 megabit per
second internet connection doing this in
4k requires a possible 30 megabits per
second
there are currently 65 countries which
have an average fixed internet
connection above 30 megabits per second
and 76 countries over 25 megabits per
second so for some parts of the world it
should be manageable even if it isn't
possible now it will be in the future of
Internet infrastructure as technologies
such as 5g advanced internet speeds stay
Diaz architecture is on top of the
Google data center network which
consists of fiber-optic links between
hundreds of points with over 7500 edge
nodes all over the world this means that
you're more likely to have a node near
you
and hence a faster connection Google
says that in the future this network
will be able to handle 8k resolution at
120 frames per second or more Google's
catchphrase for stadia is that the data
center is your platform at its core this
means that game developers aren't
limited to the processing power of a
console they can build whatever they
want and Google will scale up as
required to suit the gamers needs in
theory this is incredible at one point
Google touted that currently its stadia
is more powerful than the ps4 and Xbox
one combined this is an attractive
proposal to developers and it's crucial
as ultimately developers will have to
make the games available on stadia if
Google sells develop us on stadia then
more than likely it's going to also sell
the public on the idea Google has
already announced some partnerships with
some big names in the industry like
unreal unity and havoc they have also
announced their own developer studio and
also that a popular game Doom eternal
will be coming to Stadium
so cloud gaming does seem to be the
future but the question is will it be
Google's Microsoft's Xbox has been
developing cloud gaming for the past two
years
and Google's announcement of stadia have
prompted Microsoft's head of gaming to
claim that the Xbox also has a big move
coming
while PlayStation has been offering
cloud gaming for the past three years
it's been filled with many faults
previously if the service was restricted
to streaming on Windows PCs and only in
March of 2019 if they allow streaming on
Mac and Android the issues that you
still need a console at this stage Sony
hasn't yet announced a console this
feature for their service in fact Sony
has done the opposite with their
president stating that they'll build the
next generation Hardware Amazon is also
in the mix the company hasn't made any
big announcement but according to their
job listings page there's openings for
cloud gaming engineers Nvidia and valve
are also embarking on their cloud gaming
ventures but are finding it difficult to
secure devices like Google has this is
because stadia will run through Google
Chrome giving Google and inside edge
another factor that will determine the
success of stadia is the price a stadia
boss Phil Harrison was a former
executive for both Microsoft and Sony so
Google should be confident in hitting
the correct price point in comparison to
the competitors Phil purposely declined
commenting on the price or even the
potential revenue streams of stadia it's
possible it could be a per game purchase
or even a more interesting Netflix style
service where users pay a monthly cost
to have access to a library of games
whatever approach is decided missing the
mark here could prove to be the end
before it's even begun so wrapping up
the Stadio announcement is definitely a
game changer if Google delivers on its
promise it could mean the end of the
Xbox and Playstation altogether
of course the vision is still a while
away and there are a lot of hurdles to
overcome before stadia gets there but
there's a lot to be optimistic about
with stadia so just remember this day it
could be the day that Google kills the
game console playing any game anywhere
with just a screen and internet
connection sounds like an amazing
proposition let me know what your
thoughts are about this anyway that's it
this has been - go go and you've been
watching ColdFusion thanks for watching
and I'll catch you again soon for the
next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Music]